WELCOME BACK EVERYONE.
WHERE CHINA IS WALKING DOWN
ANOTHER CITY OVER COVID-19.
CONCERNS AS OFFICIALS WORK TO
CONTAIN THE OUTBREAKS AHEAD OF
THE WINTER OLYMPICS.
AND WE'RE NOW MONTH AWAY FROM
THE OPENING CEREMONY IN BEIJING,
WHEN PLANS ARE IN PLACE TO TRY
AND KEEP THE VIRUS AT BAY.
THE OLYMPIC OFFICIALS HELD A
NEWS CONFERENCE, SAID JUST A
FEW HOURS AGO --
CNN LIVE WATSON IS TRACKING
DEVELOPMENTS AND JOINS US NOW
LIVE FROM HONG KONG.
GOOD TO SEE YOU IVAN.
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON CHINA'S
AIMS TO VENT COVID FROM
DERAILING THE BEIJING WINTER
OLYMPIC GAMES?
>> RIGHT, WHILE CHINA HAS
MAINTAINED THIS ZERO COVID
STRATEGY WHERE IT TRIES TO
ERADICATE ANY OUTBREAK OF THE
VIRUS, IN THE COUNTRY.
AND IT HAS SUCCEEDED TO A LARGE
PART IN PREVENTING THE KIND OF
SPREADS THAT WE SEE IN SO MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES, AROUND THE
WORLD.
BUT ON THE FLIP SIDE, WHAT YOU
GET IS WHEN THERE IS A POCKET
OF THE VIRUS, AN OUTBREAK.
AN ENTIRE CITY, OF SOME 13
MILLION PEOPLE CAN PAY THE
PRICE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THE CITY OF SHIYAN, NOW.
SINCE REALLY DECEMBER 23RD IT
BEEN UNDER STRICT LOCKDOWN.
13 MILLION RESIDENTS, IN A CITY
THAT SINCE --
THE BEGINNING OF DECEMBER OF
HAD LESS THAN 2000 COVID CASES.
NO CONVERT DEATHS DUE TO COVID,
BUT ALL THE RESIDENTS ARE
CONFINED TO THEIR HOMES.
THEY CANNOT EVEN LEAVE TO GET
GROCERIES, FOR EXAMPLE.
IT'S ONLY TO GET COVID TESTS.
AND WHILE THE NUMBER OF CASES
HAS STARTED TO DROP FROM THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS, DOWN TO
JUST 35 NEW CONFIRMED CASES ON
TUESDAY, WE ARE ALSO HEARING
ANECDOTALLY, ABOUT THE KIND OF
REALLY DISTURBING IMPACTS OF
THAT IS HAPPENING ON THE
COMMUNITY.
ONE VIDEO COMING OUT, A VERY
HEAVILY CENSORED CHINESE SOCIAL
MEDIA, SHOWING A WOMAN OUTSIDE
A HOSPITAL IN SHE ON WHO IS
VISIBLY BELIEVING AND THE POST
DESCRIBED HER AS BEING 8 MONTHS
PREGNANT AND NOT BEING ALLOWED
INTO THE HOSPITAL, AND
SUBSEQUENTLY MISCARRYING.
WE'VE TRIED TO CONFIRM THIS.
WE'VE TRIED TO REACH OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL.
THEY'VE TOLD US THE WOMAN IS IN
FACT OKAY, BUT A PROVINCIAL WAS
AN INSECT SOCIALIZATION SAYS
IT'S GONNA BE EXACT
INVESTIGATING THAT CASE,
ROSEMARY.
ANOTHER CASE SHOWING A MAN
FORCED TO MAKE A CONFESSION, ON
CAMERA, BY VILLAGE OFFICIALS.
BY THE NEIGHBORHOOD VOLUNTEERS.
THAT HE HAD STALE THE WALLS OF
HIS COMPOUND TO TRY AND BUY
GROCERIES.
AND SUBSEQUENTLY, THOSE
VOLUNTEERS HAVE HAD TO
APOLOGIZE TO THAT MAN, AND EVEN
STATE MEDIA CONCEDING THAT THIS
IS REALLY TOUGH ON THE
POPULATION.
THE HARSHEST LOCKDOWN THAT
ANYONE HAS SEEN SINCE THE VIRUS
WAS FIRST DETECTED IN THE CITY
OF WUHAN, IN DECEMBER OF 2019,
BELIEVED TO BE THE ORIGIN POINT
OF COVID.
THAT THEN SUBSEQUENTLY SPREAD
AROUND THE WORLD.
IF YOU WANT ANOTHER EXAMPLE,
YOU LOOK 7 COLORS EAST IN THE
CITY OF SHANK SHOW, THERE YOU
ONLY HAVE 2 SYMPTOMATIC CASES,
AND 9 ASYMPTOMATIC CASES.
AND ALREADY ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS, POTENTIALLY
BILLIONS OF PEOPLE --
ALSO BEING PUT UNDER A SIMILAR
LOCKDOWN.
THIS IS THE PRICE THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE TO PAY, FOR
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY TO BE SPARED
RIGHT NOW FROM THE COVID
OUTBREAKS THAT ARE RAGING
ACROSS MUCH OF THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
ROSEMARY?
>> THESE ARE DRACONIAN MEASURES,
AREN'T THEY?
WE ARE ALSO HEARING ABOUT NEW
RESTRICTIONS IN HONG KONG,
WHERE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT?
THAT >> THIS IS JUST BEEN
ANNOUNCED NO MONTHS AGO, IN A
BRIEFING THAT STILL UNDERWAY.
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF HONG
KONG SAYING THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO CLOSE RESTAURANTS AFTER 6 PM,
STARTING ON FRIDAY.
THEY ARE GOING TO SHUT DOWN A
NUMBER OF OTHER LEISURE
ACTIVITIES AS WELL, AND THIS IS
BECAUSE THEY REALIZE THAT THERE
IS OMICRON SPREAD HAPPENING
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AFTER
NEARLY 3 MONTHS WITHOUT ANY
LOCAL TRANSMISSION.
THAT EVERY WILL TRACK RECORD
HAS BEEN BROKEN, AND NOW THE
AUTHORITIES ARE TRYING TO LOCK
DOWN FOR THE NEXT 2 WEEKS.
INCLUDING, BANNING ALL
PASSENGER FLIGHTS, FROM 8
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING AUSTRALIA,
THE U.S., FRANCE, IN THE UK,
THE PHILIPPINES, INDIA,
PAKISTAN IN ANOTHER DRAMATIC
ANNOUNCEMENT THEY ARE CREATING
A MANDATORY QUARANTINE FOR SOME
3000 PLUS PASSENGERS AND CREW
WHO WERE ON A CRUISE SHIP TO
NOR WHERE.
WITH RESTRICTIONS SO INTENSE
HERE IN HONG KONG, WHERE YOU
HAVE TO DO UP TO 3 WEEKS OF
MANDATORY QUARANTINE IF YOU
RETURN FROM ANY TRAVEL OVERSEAS.
PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE FOR SOME
SUN KIND OF ENTERTAINMENT,
THEY'RE GETTING ON THESE CRUISE
SHIPS ARE JUST KIND OF TOOLING
AROUND THE SEA, AND NOW ONE
SHIP THAT HAD 9 CLOSE CONTACTS
TO A POSITIVE CASE.
BECAUSE OF THAT, BECAUSE THEY
WERE ON BOARD THE SHIP.
NOW 3000 PEOPLE, PLUS BEING
SENT INTO MANDATORY QUARANTINE.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MEASURES
THAT THE HONG KONG GOVERNMENT
ARE IMPOSING.
IRONICALLY, ON NEW YEAR'S EVE,
THE GOVERNMENT ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY BELIEVE THERE ARE THESE
FIRST POSITIVE CASES MERGING
WITHIN THE CITY, AND THEY SAID
THEY ARE PER URGING PEOPLE NOT
TO GATHER IN LARGE GROUPS.
BUT THEY STILL ALLOWED LARGE
GOVERNMENT SPONSORED NEW YEAR'S
CONCERT TO GO FORWARD.
THAT WAS ATTENDED BY THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
SO APPARENTLY THEY WAIT AFTER
THOSE GOVERNMENT EVENTS TO
ANNOUNCE THESE NEW MEASURES.
BACK TO YOU ROSEMARY.
>> IVAN WATSON, JOINING US LIVE
FROM HONG KONG, MANY THANKS FOR
THAT.
AND OF COURSE THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC, SEVERAL COUNTRIES AND
TERRITORIES HAVE AIMED FOR A
ZERO COVID STRATEGY.
MAINLAND CHINA AND HONG KONG OF
COURSE ARE COMMITTED TO KEEPING
THEIR LIVES ON THIS CHART FROM
SPIKING.
HONG KONG SAID TIGHT-KNIT
VACCINATION WERE QUARANTINE
EVEN FURTHER.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE CARRIE LAM SAYS
PEOPLE MUST BE VACCINATED TO
ENTER THEIR NEWS INCLUDING
MUSEUMS, LIBRARIES AND SCHOOLS
FROM FEBRUARY 24TH.
NOT THIS IS ON TOP OF STRICT
BORDER RULES.
SO WHAT TOLL THAT ARE ALL THESE
RESTRICTIONS TAKING.
WE'LL SEE WITH THESE ARE
LOOKING AT LONG TERM TRAVEL
PROBLEMS WARRANTIES.
IN ZERO COVID HONG KONG AND
DEMIGOD --
HAS THIS ONE'S DECISION THEY
JUST TAKE MINUTES NOW DRAGS ON
FOR OUR.
MANDATORY TESTING FOR AT THE
AIRPORT, WAITING HOURS FOR THE
RESULT.
THE LUCKY ONES, TEST NEGATIVE.
SPENT 21 DAYS IN SELF PAY
QUARANTINE.
THERE ARE CHAN IS NOT ONE OF
THE LUCKY ONES.
>> I'VE HAD --
I DIDN'T EVER THINK THAT I
WOULD TEST POSITIVE ON THE WAY
HOME.
13 HOURS AFTER LANDING IN HONG
KONG, CHAN WAS IN AN AMBULANCE.
HIS LUGGAGE, LEFT OF THE
AIRPORT.
HE TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE
OMICRON VARIANT.
EVEN WITHOUT SYMPTOMS.
HIS MINIMUM HOSPITAL STAY, IS
NEARLY A MONTH.
>> DO YOU WORRY ABOUT YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH THESE DAYS?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE THE NERVE IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS BEFORE.
>> IN GENERAL, THERE'S AN
INCREASED SENSE OF ISOLATION,
ANXIETY.
AND IT SEEMS TO BE THE CASES
THAT ARE POSITIVE ARE GIVING.
STRESS >> HONG KONG'S --
ELIZABETH WONG SAYS LONGER
QUARANTINES CAN BE MORE
TRAUMATIC.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF CHANGES
WITH THE 7 DAYS, AND THE 14
DAYS, AND THE 21 DAYS.
AND THAT IS WHEN PEOPLE
REPORTED --
ESPECIALLY WITH LONGER PERIODS
OF QUARANTINE.
BARRELS DAY BEGINS WITH THE
WAKE OF JAMIE.
ATTENTION PLEASE.
>> HE TAKES HIS OWN VIBE.
OF CALLS AND MESSAGES FRIENDS
AND FAMILY TO HELP PASS THE
TIME.
>> SOCIAL MEDIA HAS REALLY
HELPED, ACTUALLY.
A DEADLY MAKES YOU FEEL NOT
ALONE.
>> ONE OF HIS GREATEST
STRUGGLES, SHARING A ROOM AND A
BATHROOM WITH 2 STRANGERS.
>> I THINK WOULD'VE DEFINITELY
IMPACTED ME SO FAR AS THE
FEELING OF --
NOT HAVING THE FREEDOM AND
REGRESSING ALMOST LIKE YOU'RE
BACK AT SCHOOL.
WITH A CONTROLLED WAKE UP, AND
TIMES.
NOT BEING ABLE TO CONTROL WE
CAN EAT.
>> HOSPITAL MEALS OFTEN
CONSISTS OF, MR. MEAT.
THE BIGGEST MYSTERY?
JAN'S RELEASE DATE.
HE'S SUPPOSED TO START A NEW
JOB, A NEW LIFE, IN HONG KONG.
>> WHAT'S THE WORST PART OF?
THIS >> I THINK THE WORST PART
IS NOT KNOWING WHEN I'LL BE
ABLE TO GET OUT.
>> FOR NOW, ALL YOU CAN DO IS
WA